صار الجلسات المحكمه يمرر الرسائل نصائح
للشعب العراقي
فكان يتواصل نعم مع يعني بعض فصائل
المقاومه العراقيه وهو في الاصل وهو في
الاسر نعم كان يتعامل وكانوا يستشيروه حتى
ببعض الامور يعني
كل ذلك كان يحصل عبرك فقط
من خلال جلسات
من خلال لقاءات ومع اخرين
وتمرر له بعض المعلومات يعني بصيغه مشفره
او بصيغه غير مفهومه يعني اغلب الامور
اللي تمر الا بطريقه مشفره كان يلتقط ذلك
مباشره
يعني يعرف عن ذلك يعلن عن ذلك في خلال
المحاكمات ذكي جدا هو بجانب التشفير ذكي
جدا يعني في بعض الاحيان كان في بعض
المصطلحات اللي يستخدمها مثلا في خلال
محاكماته يكون قصدها على انها شيفره مثلا
يدعوهم للصمود او يدعوهم للمقاومه واحيانا
يقول هلا بصريح العباره
قوات المسلحه المجاهده
[موسيقى]